day two of hashtag mug Club quarantine
entering the promo code quarantine
atlatl credit.com / mug club and you get
$30 off for the whole month of April we
understand that a lot of you out there
are lonely you need more content we're
not doctors we're not emergency
responders but we can create good -
mediocre content for you on a daily
basis and we're making all of it free in
front of the paywall
and of course adding morning shows
Monday Wednesday Friday good morning Mon
Club at 10:00 p.m. Eastern we really
appreciate it one of the things people
who are already members of Mudd Club
please do consider renewing because
since you last signed death we've been
demonetized in public enemy number one
so we do need you it's what keeps this
going and I really hope that you spend
time with us this month and enjoy the
show
[Music]
[Music]
hello that's called the covering up
self-conscious because there's a new
black rifle shirt but it's a little it's
an extra-large it's a little snug you
can see my nips
so join me free of Freemont Club for the
month they're like a Thursday show of
course in third year we have my half
agent Larry bill Richman still here
cover is there wait and there are you we
have a guest coming on 11 if the
surprise guest I don't feel like non you
because you should have been following
along on social media if you should
before we move on to talk about all of
the things in the news not mostly
coronavirus related because we know that
you're a little bit tired yeah before we
get to that in Mexico it should be noted
girls still throw like girls
they can't even domestic terrorism
properly that's why you gotta go
slingshots just scarole everybody's okay
the protest chance and homeward bound
with a lobster by the way bill de blasio
this happened he went to went to the gym
his officials they urged him you know to
socially distance limit coronaviruses
he's going to save the state of New York
by curling in the squat rack good for
him little bit inside you and if some
CrossFitters think that's funny they
should either or orthopedic surgeons
bill oh yeah we expect me after you know
mayor de Blasio he says he was he was
pleased with the New York's response to
the corona virus meanwhile should be no
the citizens of Detroit remain unfazed
by the virus because they've all been
murdered ah yeah oh yeah that's one way
out it helps Detroit it's a little bit
less consequential there that should be
like the last thing you to stop the
spread of the virus put it on the table
this or social distancing as they cut
you know six feet apart that's the rule
or in Detroit as they call it coming
together even then it's mostly wildlife
how do we socially distance myself in
downtown Metro Detroit from a bear
running around stabbing us with
everything I sprayed it down with the
Clorox but it just seems to irritate him
more
we're supposed to were all in this
together let's bridge the party windows
boy also has anyone seen my arm
Vaughn oh by the way bono wrote a
coronavirus song dedicated to it it's
great let your love be known as the u2
front men's first new music since 2017
so for those who haven't heard this
right that means that when you open your
iTunes this morning your phone will have
automatically downloaded the coronavirus
it's going to be what are you saying I
still feel bad for them because they had
to learn in one day how much everybody
hates yeah I don't know how he sings
yeah incredibly irritating I give
everyone the gift of you - if this was a
free gift and everyone still wanted a
refund
they said yo seriously this is worse
yeah they've stayed there welcome home
alright and by the way I'm sure you've
been reading about a lot of these
coronavirus stories if you don't laugh
you'll um die from the corona virus so
stay home after laugh enjoy the streams
that Japanese students they held
actually graduation ceremony in
Minecraft
huh in the game of Minecraft was amazing
well yeah the real ceremony of course
was canceled due to the coronavirus
shutdown so they played it in the
Minecraft world and sadly tragedy struck
when none other gamers became bored
after playing call of duty so there was
a crossover with that's prestige level
right there a good thing is they dropped
pixelated leaflets beforehand to let
everyone know to let you know yeah Harry
Truman war criminal or American hero
both no general Curtis LeMay said
afterwards if we had won I would be
tried as a war criminal so pretty much
everything yes no I mean I'm just saying
like anyone would have considered that
to be not great wasn't necessary it was
it definitely considered necessary at
the time did it hasten the end of the
war and save lives absolutely right was
it still a great thing
nothing crazy no there's nothing right
about World War two yeah I would argue
but it's in context of quote nobody's
saying it's a great event that happened
like we're not celebrating the fact that
people had to die even mind we did just
make a joke about it and I'm craft
no I exactly none of us have a leg to
stand on is what I'm saying
no credibility it's still bad yeah no no
I agree not a war criminal absolutely
saved more lives and it took when you
look at what I would have taken you with
a land war but yeah you know listen I'm
not necessarily thrilled about it except
for sometimes when I am speaking of a
quiet handles about animals there was a
second dolphin not coronavirus related
oh yeah you get a break Oh was she found
shot dead off the Florida coast oh man
it's comes from the New York Post for
some reason even though it's about
Florida there's also a growing concern
that there are more but they will not
hit the beach and be detected and when
asked if they knew anything about the
dolphins a local fisherman stated stalks
get shot fam and so that seems like he's
so man little insects are the old man in
the sea gol de que yeah detail the
tattoos and the knuckles yes that's like
then that's like fish fishermen whose
post Malone really enjoyed he's ready
for the waves he's ready for the rain
he's ready for those talking dolphins
Somali pirates apparently great for all
of them know what really buy you guys
we've been hearing this quite a bit any
time dolphins stories come up there's
always somebody comes towards you know
dolphins are smarter than humans how
often we've been more often czar harder
than people and okay I understand that
some people may argue in forms of
communication or communicate
communicative patterns that that may or
may not be true but let's let's be real
here that as a general rule dolphins as
a species they're actually pretty dumb
[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
I wrote that we were taping a Midnight
Cowboy yeah well make it in the shower
no you know he was videotaping me seven
because they use a word videotape to
watch a VHS tapes and we've been punting
this for like six weeks because we just
haven't found the right place to fit in
flat earth dolphin then I am 90%
convinced that the earth is a globe 98
just lay it on the table as a girl cuz I
don't care about the oxidants um
cross-contamination apparently it's not
good for you really really narrow er
they say grilling meat causes cancer
because of the char but you also hear
more ya'll believe that you also get
more what's what's the word I'm looking
for not oxidants antioxidant engines
okay
like so many carcinogens of meat yeah
but you also get more carcinogens than
you would eat a few eat steaks everyday
in like one shiitake mushroom oh well so
that's really now I gotta start eating
shitake mushrooms mister make up for I
don't know a shiitake mushroom I
wouldn't recognize a shiitake mushroom I
hate them if it walked in which are the
ones that are full mushrooms but smaller
I don't know okay okay wait did you guys
notice that Gerald a changed his shirt
because he spilled something on it
that's the beauty of doing this not
exactly live but tomorrow we'll be live
of course good morning my club will be
taking your shadow morning a.m. Eastern
stories that oh look
all my club month okay so uh this is
something that I want to talk about
because it pissed me off and why am I
doing this I don't know you're rubbing
oh my gosh do you join up yeah antique
immerse ya subscribers went down really
so my question to you when it comes to
the handling of the the Chinese virus
have you heard the media celebrate any
of the innovations made by the private
sector you talking about retooling your
factories for masks for testing for
treatment for therapeutics I think that
it's journalistic malpractice that these
aren't being shouted from the rooftops
right now yeah it's
why don't we want to give people hope it
seemed that they want to give people
false hope in this idea of Medicare for
all our socialized health care system
because of course this is what we need
to talk about the claim that we're
seeing from the left on the corona virus
pandemic is that we wouldn't have these
problems if we had universal health care
the public sector could make all of us
go away
here's them saying it because you don't
take my word for it
we will talk I'm sure about Medicare for
all but when I talk about health care
being a human
right and all people having health care
the coronavirus crisis makes that
abundantly clear as to why it should be
wrong is the coronavirus the best case
for Medicare let's reverse that show
virus is a very good case looking in
through the lens of an aquarium there is
no middle ground when it comes to
dealing with a national security threat
and medicare for again is an example of
a policy that would take on that threat
with the seriousness that it requires to
be taken on what would Medicare for all
do it would insure that people actually
could get a test for coronavirus that
they could get treatment for the
coronavirus come come again [ __ ]
here's the thing I don't think we could
have a more crystal clear case that the
exact opposite is true covin 19 the
Chinese virus wolf flute whatever you
want to call it there has never been
more of a crystallization as to the need
for private industry due to the sheer
ineptitude of the government they talk
about the corner compares to other
countries this is something that
actually I stumbled across let's take
the countries at the top of the World
Health Organization their rankings right
there right that's 30 cents right next
to Slovenia now let's take them with a
comparable population size to the United
States let's look at their total deaths
and deaths per capita Italy's number two
and Spain's number seven whoops we
barely edged out Slovenia here's the
true government muck this up private
industry is fixing it and they're being
held responsible with fixing it so there
are a few examples that we can walk
through as to why you shouldn't entrust
all of your health all of your health
and health care needs to the government
let's go back to the Obama
administration right they never
replenish the stockpile of masks after
the Ebola scare now I know I know people
can be upset you can blame Donald Trump
for not accepting masks from China
here's the thing the truth is a lot of
these masks and test kits from China
they've had to be recalled
yeah the countries that use them they're
pre infected so they didn't know they
came pre in fact yeah it was the pre
infected version you don't want they
thought it was like a cigar roller wait
one cigar in every box it like box of 25
it's not greeting it's not a pregnancy
test
oh my bad it's kind of like those
smallpox blankets same come I already
pay shipping so first
what are you talking about if they got
socialized healthcare everyone will be
able to be tested right that guy's yes
No so let's be quick that it couldn't be
more dishonest that is if today we're
opposite day like if we were going into
scouts where they have opposite day and
everyone wears their clothes on
backwards because it's fun and we like
to have a laugh he would be tops but
here's another truth for you at first
the CDC was the only place approved by
the FDA to make the testing kits oh
right the CDC refused testing kits and
capabilities from the private sector and
we all know how that turned out only
once the private sector industry was
allowed to step up and this is keep in
mind tooth they were already stepping up
but they weren't allowed to did we see
the improvement since then what do we
have we have Unitas these companies have
developed the fasting test but fasting
testing kits fastest testing kits in the
world I'm sure you are tested or not
you're fasting yes so let's roll to
helps I don't know I'm not a discerning
but I would advise avoid eating a fatty
meal before the swab yeah so the fastest
testing kit in the world Abbott
Laboratories I have that name right yeah
yeah I'm at us company they mented a
kovat test five minutes boom you get rid
of used only earlier this week and then
they were topped by another company
bodies fear developed a two-minute test
that was approved today choose the magic
number two minute Cove it'd testing
stick that your pipe and kill yourself
with it CDC yeah that sounds like the
private industry stepping in work it
sounds like I mean almost a monopoly
didn't work and now and I know you're
wondering the bahasa and the CDC at
least they're held to some kind of
accountability right and they're better
than most private companies no and which
private companies are they they're worse
than all of them so then all here's
another here's another problem not
learning for the mistakes the FDA
they're still preventing private
companies from creating as many tests as
possible they're only approving 100,000
a day when these companies could be
upping it to a hundred and sixty
thousand a day the government
government is not here to help I just
want to make that very clear by the way
hit the notification bell if you're
subscribed hit all notifications so
you're notified what everybody goes up
goes up at 9 p.m. eastern of course
bug Club quarantine all month $30 off
romo code quarantine and we are doing
morning shows live talking with you at
10:00 a.m. so each one of those guys
that was on in that video of the gals as
well claimed that if we had universal
attorney loose very loosely very loosely
claimed if we had universal health care
people could be treated and tested right
we obviously know we just went through
the test the treatment part well what do
governments around the world that have
universal health care or something like
it tend to have more hospitals than they
need do they tend to have really short
wait times like your video when you went
undercover in Canada was that a short
wait time to get into seasons early
that's the only way you could have had
everybody treated is if you had millions
of people beds laying around waiting on
patients right weren't being used that's
a stockpile we didn't have more and
nurses and more and doctors now and
everything else they made claims that
they cannot back up at all no it
couldn't be fixed at all and by the way
here's something else just to show you
that how smug the media is remember they
they mocked Donald Trump mercilessly
when he made this suggestion just either
I think it might have been earlier this
week at the most
last week they're throwing away the mask
right away they're thrown away and when
you hear 55 million masks world I'm
saying 55 million how could it possibly
be such a number and they say oh that's
just a small fraction of what we need
and I said why are we sanitizing this
you know you look at the mess I've
looked at all the different masks some
don't LED themselves to doing that I
think but many do and I said why aren't
we have very good liquids for doing this
sanitizing the masks and that's
something there they're starting to do
more and more the sanitizing the masks
okay a couple of things here first off
this was assumed to be crazy was leftist
outlets claiming irresponsible why
citing federal guidelines because the
federal guidelines would of course be
correct here's a thing we also need to
separate what Donald Trump says from the
soundbite that you see on Twitter when
you hear that oh of course in its
totality
okay that makes sense he says even
hedges his words some masks maybe some
mats not but you have to understand the
difference between what Donald Trump
says sometimes and what he means well we
we had some very thin liquidus of the
media says he just thinks she can spray
sand Everclear on it and call it a day
know what he was talking about with some
kind of a system to make masks reusable
recycling you should be fans of that
right no well careful block your mouth
don't let this tin can about to kick hit
you in the teeth you pieces because
Patel a non-profit started using this
mask sanitization technology now have
machines that can sanitize 80,000 masks
a day in Ohio are shipping machines to
other states they'll hopefully result in
400,000 masks being cleaned per day so I
get it him cigarettes are verified
liquids okay very final equation best in
babies support whatever it is that you
want to assume he's saying it's not that
crazy no and he said we should be
looking into this and by the way in a
crisis you do start to go hey we have to
change how we're doing things we don't
have enough masks in a crisis we need to
change the rules a little bit and still
maintain sanitize not only and we'll get
to a private industry stepping up and
creating more masks right
but now you've increased the ability to
exponentially because you can use masks
that you already have every single
journalist should be talking about how
now they can sanitize tens or hundreds
of thousands of masks per day we are
going to have hundreds of thousands new
masks made because of private industry
who stepped up who by the way didn't
even have to be forced to buy the
defense production act and approve the
drug that Donald Trump was touting last
week that you said was irresponsible
because there was no kind of medical
basis you're wrong you're wrong and you
should be happy that you're wrong
because it's going to save I mean let's
be honest dozens of lives with this
pandemic here going on here's another
claim that they've made quite a bit that
other countries with the socialized
health care systems that they've somehow
done better than ISIL implement but the
federal government the Trump
administration watching the rollout of
testing for this virus it continues to
set the United States apart FDA
Financial Times in London today put out
this graph showing how how well various
countries are doing in terms of testing
for the virus when you look at the best
you know system in the world that's
something that's up for debate
South Korea we're up to South Korea has
up to 10,000 tests per day they've been
able to provide tests to any single
person that wants it
and here people are scrambling okay all
right so let's get back to South Korea
let's go back to Burt Ward's comments
there Burt Madame country that they're
talking about who they've praised for
years of course based on the World
Health Organization's ranking which by
the way I love now that no one can ever
use that again The Young Turks Network
the leftist organizations you can't say
well we ranked behind what France Italy
Spain do we really want to talk about
that anymore we always knew that was the
case because the subjective polling but
now you know it's the case because the
entire world has seen it once Italy said
you know what you're over 60 you're on
your own and that's not so old they
retire at like 35 in Italy they don't
create anything that benefits the rest
of the world pasta was Chinese
piss off really so didn't know that
let's look at Italy with a nationalized
health care system right they had by far
the highest death rates and its
population quite elderly of course the
intensive care units they were just
advice just they said what do we do with
these elderly people and as well I don't
just don't just don't do anything but
what do we do how do we help them we
just don't help them because we don't we
can't I mean we can't raise taxes
anymore and people don't work yeah but
you said we call the government and the
wait time they talk about this before
the wait times are terrible we've talked
about this with all these countries you
can go back and watch you're socialized
health care videos and if you have a
broken arm or something to them it's a
nuisance because it's non-essential like
a nosebleed but now when it comes to a
pandemic there can be no debate there's
no denying that the wait times increase
the mortality rates of that it's work
and at the very least it's a violation
of human rights to not allow people to
purchase privatized health care which is
increasingly rare in these countries but
that was the case in Canada at least
until 2005 let's go to South Korea by
the way this is one that really bothers
me as people point to South Korea sure
they do they were ahead of us on testing
absolutely because they quickly
mobilized and what do they do they use
the private sector for testing kits
which the CDC here said no no you can't
do now that we're doing it we're
surpassing South Korea very quickly oh
yeah also something that when people
point to South Korea as a successful
example of the social distancing
protocols they effectively doxed their
own citizens yeah they were tracking the
phones of citizens and then released
detailed information to the public via
apps including age descriptions and
movements over the past few days the
people could say Oh
okay I see man have a sneeze go Tupac we
kill him so if we want to something
really important because when they in
trying to demonize the United States
because of the Communists sympathizing
media and I mean that because they were
actually parroting Communist Chinese
government talking points I see it
without a hint of piper Billie Piper
Billy hi Polly
hyperbole is hyperbole and I throw a
pipe at the camera there we go 3d show
on TV without a hint of hyperbole this
media who is sympathetic to the Chinese
government they will take any
opportunity to demonize the American
government at all costs well when you
tell them we should we should be like
South Korea let the American public know
what they did Americans you think they
have a have a greater success rate here
in dealing with Corona okay if you just
want to use them on one metric but are
you willing to turn over all of your
phone's data there are you willing to
turn over all your location services not
to your private web searching on your
iPhone you want to turn that over the
government so they can release it to the
public because mouth Korea did I know
you could kill everybody who has this
virus as well and have zero new cases
right you do that and just report hey
we're doing we killed it's kind of like
Russia yeah right we don't hear anything
out of Russia I guarantee you they have
something there like I'll just kill him
that's what happening yeah you don't see
them anymore
have you seen your assistant bring her
coffee no no no no no why she needs
their souls to sustain herself so
another truth we weren't as far along as
other countries that's true once we
started testing and we started testing
more people in eight days I think
eventually then that South Korea tested
in eight weeks once we started testing
and now of course we have more
privatized industries we talked about
stepping up so we can test more people
again bottleneck CDC socialized
government that's what we're talking
about here right socialized healthcare
run by the government versus private
industry coming out with a five minute
test and a two minute test I bet you the
next one you it'll just you just start
to say the word test into the test like
you're positive yeah just
it could tell by my Veilleux terrible
test more than any other country in the
world right now as far as that so that
talking point is gone as well
here's another point that they'll still
make another area where the United
States actually by the way is doing
really well because of the private
sector independent researchers they
found success was combination therapy we
don't have a cure but we do have what
they call therapeutics we do have
treatment Donald Trump went up and
talked about chloroquine chloroquine
chloroquine chloroquine chloroquine
chloroquine I don't care fish tank just
go home to South Fidel just take a shot
and tell us how it works out though dill
says he was mocked across the media
right this is you're responsible
well now it's FDA approved in
emergencies it was already an FDA drug
because of its safety profile but now
it's FDA approved specifically for
coronavirus but before that a private
practitioner had prescribed an off-label
had 699 people who were treated
successfully not to mention all the
independent testing which we talked
about on this channel and this is really
concerning Twitter and YouTube were
removing or censoring videos that talked
about chloroquine as fake news or talked
about Chinese masks being faulty they've
removed some of these tweets and videos
how scary is that when these people are
in charge of of fact-checking and not
only are they dishonest but they are
dishonest in the way in a way that could
save thousands of life yeah yeah
absolutely and then the story goes out
about the fish tank cleaner that we've
covered at nauseam here and they put
that out everywhere yeah man and woman
died when taking Trump's advice I'm like
wait how's that up and this is an
everything see how many more stories
have you seen out there about a dumbass
drinking fish tank cleaner than you have
compared to the Mike hip pillow guy
being able to create 15,000 masks today
400,000 masks being sanitized and the
fact that that drug not the fish tank
cleaner is now FDA approved because I
haven't heard a peep on that for nothing
can post or New York behind it but some
[ __ ] drinks poor koi pond cleaner
and that's at the top of Reddit really
do your job moderators it's not
happening I don't know they're probably
unemployed you're working from home
still no excuse when we're talking about
a vaccine
yes researchers they're working on a
vaccine and it'll probably take about a
year and a half why mo
sleep because of the FDA baggage just
for the same reasons chloroquine it's
really hard to move a barge it's
sometimes more helpful when you have
Donald Trump coming in with chloroquine
another bars going get over there get
out of the way does help it's terrible
this shows more of a tugboat it's easier
to move so here's something what we're
talking about we do have to get going
with razörfist and then we'll see you
tomorrow good morning mug club but this
is something that just bothers me so
much I don't think it could possibly be
more clear at this point that we need
the private sector the only other
country that's had success beyond daxing
its citizens when you look at South
Korea's because they did mobilize the
private sector once we started doing
that here in the United States guess
what we start doing better and guess
what else
Donald Trump starts speaking directly to
his audience with these evening press
briefings his approval rating goes up so
what do they do
let's stop airing Trump let's run a
story about people who drank fish tank
cleaner to condemn Trump for touting a
drug oh wait it's been approved by the
FDA and it actually shows some of the
grassy let's not cover it look Donald
Trump for saying that we should be able
to sanitize mess oh wait a second we
actually can do that now because private
industry stepped up to do it it's almost
like Donald Trump said this kind of
knowing what was coming around the
corner let's just silence this this is
an amazing situation for me because
after 9/11 and I know the LA girl didn't
like George Bush at the very least we
came together for the common need and
right now we're fighting this sort of
invisible enemy I know some people
saying it's not technically invisible he
pin microscope I don't care the point
here is that I don't know if it'll ever
be a time now where we'll come together
again against an enemy if something
could ever help us find common ground
yeah it would be this right here and I
don't just mean fighting a virus but I
mean the idea that we are making
unbelievable headway and we're making
headway not from tearing people away
from their jobs in place of business and
having them holed up in their apartments
though some people need to continue
doing that obviously but we're making
headway because of American businesses
innovating and stepping forward to save
fellow Americans lives I know it's a bad
narrative because one of them to
capitalism is greedy and bad but guess
what
these people are willing to sacrifice
their businesses capabilities to step up
for the greater good and the fact that
these stories are not front page
everywhere at a time when the American
public is panicked and you could offer
them a sliver of
hope is to me not only dishonest it is
journalistic malpractice I don't even
know if that's a real thing because
you're not really held to any kind of
standard like a lawyer or a doctor but
if you could be we hang you up at dawn
before breakfast figuratively speaking
of course not literally none I just want
you fired and on the unemployment line
with everyone else who you've harmed
let's get to mr. Fitz black rifle coffee
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
all right you gonna have to you have to
soften my mic your audio wait you ready
ready soften it cuz I don't want to blow
everyone's ear drums out okay all right
that's fine you can bring me back up the
lights are flickering every now and then
what's going on here there are gremlins
and the lights
speaking of gremlin because they're
unsightly and a little bit of a nuisance
but they tend to be clever especially
that old lady on the chairlift yeah
right when they launched her like a
catapult from the foot like a trebuchet
really really yeah although actually our
next guest he can he can delineate for
so I know the difference in a trebuchet
even though I'm French and a catapult or
a proper trebuchet you can follow on the
Twitter at raise your fist zero is the
raise or fist and of course he has the
rageaholic YouTube channel good friend
of the show mr. fist how are you sir
good to be back how the hell are you sir
I'm doing fine what do you think safe
from the pinko pox over there are
unfortunately in an area with a lot of
Asians but I find that they tolerate
racism quite well if they walk up and
they go like excuse me what's the
difference between a trebuchet and a
catapult is it that one has the rope oh
it's an old person I think it's a hag a
pole is that the square tying Nancy
Pelosi to the end of it and launching
rabbit I think that's actually how they
do her facelifts exactly
well they just swing it back on her face
and she just stands it like in that yeah
was that ibis Miller said it looks like
she's perpetually pulling 5 G's in a
wind tunnel yes that's exactly correct I
used to think she was actually pretty
fetching only physically I mean
spiritually she's repugnant yeah but for
an older lady she let herself defer a
very old lady she put herself together
well I want to talk about a few before
we get to the pandemic and the commie
pox you're sounding a little nasally
miss
yeah I got I got some mutant allergies
going on and it decided to wait for the
moment when we were all dying of the
Comi cough yeah that was nice that's a
nice little perpetual heart attack for
the last week and a half that was uh
that was a hootenanny
yes well I have the same issue but I
alway hon second okay first off my
throat is scratchy have I done Gilbert
God for your nick nolte recently neat on
the show and if I have that answers it
and if not I just go are my eyes itchy
as well and if my eyes are itchy it's
allergies and then I know that everyone
in public judges me no matter what I
have never had more people stand farther
away from me yeah people will just cross
it's amazing which is bizarre because if
you look at the footage out of New York
the the parks are overcrowded right so
that's it I was gonna say it's bizarre
because you know you look like you're in
a Ramones cover band and this is the
first time people across the street may
see you right but speaking of New York
I'd like to uh did you see that the the
big like red siren on top of the they
some empath in the city of New York
decided that the most effective method
of a-laying the fears of the public was
to install the the Eye of Sauron on the
top of the Empire State Building it
seems like that's honestly a difference
in world view where you know Donald
Trump said don't panic
we will get this under control and
they're like yeah yeah well see because
we hate Trump supposed to tell everybody
you're screwed you're all you know we're
all gonna die Michael it mike linville
yesterday should have been like actually
should probably smother someone with one
of these pillows right as much as I
appreciate him retooling to make masks
let's be honest the my pillow is just a
bunch of packing peanuts in a trash bag
yeah it is not comfortable because I'm a
pillow guy and my wife and I bought one
at Bed Bath we said we wouldn't buy the
pillow from the the rapist and they said
no and they said yeah we know
you shop right this way and we grabbed
it it is like pack foam packing peanuts
yeah so what does it Nick DiPaolo says
it's my pillows perfect for muffling the
screams of a ten-year-old exactly but I
think it also sort of showcases the just
the elitism of journalists when they're
mocking this guy who's building up
capacity to 50,000 masks a day right
this is his business 75% of it as being
retooled and then journalists and I
don't mean comedians I don't mean
content creators journalists create
nothing and they spend all night mocking
him mercilessly for being in a press
conference on what hey isn't this good
news that this guy is building masks is
that a good thing unless anxiety fear
and elitism is a gross domestic product
I don't know that if only he were
manufacturing toilet paper I'm sure in a
pinch is that and that may be a way to
fix the Fed because like how did how the
toilet paper become coin of the realm is
right yeah like like Kleenex
you know soup maybe water what the but
TV yeah what is everyone like subsisting
on bran muffins prune juice and dulcolax
look this is the post apocalypse I know
this is the post apocalypse I guess now
we know why all those Mad Max bad guys
whereas let's chat I think that is proof
positive that there's no logic to the
fear of the pandemic if you want to if
you believe that this thing is you know
contagion it's gonna have a 20% death
rate as the real pandemics that they
portray in the films you know the unreal
pandemics how they portray in the films
toilet paper wouldn't be a part of the
equation it's not even a digestive
effecting virus so it's remarkable to me
it just goes to show you that we human
beings particularly the American public
are far more manipulated by the media
than they realize the reaction to the
reaction is what scares me a little bit
now I do want to get to your stream
being taken down but since we're talking
about this you did do a video originally
on your channel about the Penn
coronavirus I think this was back in
February if I'm not mistaken were you
were saying that people should be on
guard and paying attention to it so you
did think it was at least a threat or
something people should be aware of yeah
I I thought you could take in mind you
this is early February so I'm trying not
to make panic buyers or anything and I'm
like well you know maybe having some
some stuff like common sense stuff like
you know a little bit of water stuff
that you're gonna eat anyway right stuff
that you're gonna use anyway would not
be so bad apparently but I think what
really it becomes a self-perpetuating
cycle though is I think when people see
empty shelves they assume well I must
need that right you know right yeah yes
and it just feels more panic buying over
and over and over again yeah and what
runs out quicker because it's gigantic
yes rage is big rolls of toilet paper of
course every single time yeah but I
think I'm finally starting to agree with
the conspiracy nuts I I think the virus
had to be man-made real ease and by
Campbell's soup Purell and the Charmin
Corporation yes every in the long ball
yeah don't forget zoom yeah this is
pretty remarkable what do you think
though since you were warning about this
and I've talked about how Donald Trump
did implement a travel ban which was
accused you know he was accused of
xenophobia by Joe Biden so the Democrats
have picked the single worst candidate
to run against Trump they're hoping
Russian and pit you know the impeachment
didn't work they're hoping the whole
Russia hook it didn't work so let's get
him on coronavirus that's why they want
to stop airing his nightly briefings
right now because his approval rating is
going up and Joe Biden really the one
thing that we know that President Trump
did differently than any other president
because I don't know how much of
president controls us but this guy did
go against the grain and Dan travel from
China and he was excoriated by the left
for it can we at least say all right you
know what that's a win for him can you
put that up on the scoreboard for me
yeah no kidding me and you know your
field of candidates is weak when they're
upstaged by a microbe there's gonna trot
out a little animated version of
coronavirus that convention like in like
in Jurassic Park
not DNA right and how about by Biden
getting me to like who could have
connected those dots huh
yeah he's i don't hire I don't buy it
because she's over 12 doesn't line up
like the ski guild with facial skin
pulled like a condom over a cantaloupe
but you know who Huff's ten year old so
gosh yeah who could have seen that
coming except Stevie Wonder let me ask
you this now since you were talking
about beforehand do you think it's
man-made which out we can get into at
some point but maybe we won't but do you
think that the response has been
proportional or do you think that
there's some hysteria for someone who
was early on this but now you see how
far it's gone how do you go oh there
were authoritarians licking their chops
waiting for this thing right they were
they were just waiting for a cut for any
kind of crisis of any proportion I think
I think frankly you go another week
maybe two and then you tell the Viet
risk people to stay home and maybe take
extra steps to keep them home and then
everybody else who's less at risk
probably needs to go back to work yeah
and get on with their lives for Christ's
sake we went back to with our lives
during the Spanish flu you know go look
at those numbers like we went on with
our lives and continued working back
then what's so special now and I we
understand the exponential growth and so
forth but the same thing was true with
the Spanish flu the same thing is true
in all pandemics frankly yeah I think at
a certain point you got to get on with
it well I said this a long time ago in
all you can't do that I said oh how
about we just quarantine old and sick
people right and let everyone else you
know try and implement social distancing
where they can wear masks wash their
hands so implement all of these these
measures that we have let people build
up a herd immunity and protect those who
are vulnerable and people said it was
crazy
now I see it suggested everywhere I get
it I'm a late-night comic people don't
take but right we put that one on the
scoreboard for my seat yeah breaking
news Crowder calls to end the Democratic
primaries exactly no it really is
remarkable that we have a list of
exclusive or sorry a list of essential
businesses seems to me we should have
created a list of non-essential
businesses that probably should have
closed down working
amination or you know transmission would
have been more likely you know like the
ball playpen at McDonald's we could have
you know put some yellow tape around it
instead we just shut everything down and
I don't know much and everyone who was
at risk was already stay at home every
anyways right that's the thing like I
was saying it's not like old people
aren't taking precautions I was saying
during the last debate every time you
know Bernie wouldn't shut up or whatever
the moderator should have just coughed
it when it cleared that stage like 2.5
seconds seriously right and you know
Bernie isn't oh he's an over corrector
as far as evading like you saw him hit
that speed bag and came back at him on
the face of the second time is a go so
you know if the person took and go out
of his chair and that would be fun
because then he'd be doing a commercial
for the bracelet fallen and I can't get
up we both hate the Chinese government I
hate the Chinese government because I
sympathize with the the Chinese people
what's your and I know you talked about
this in your in your video how do you
feel how do you view kind of the people
who have to live under this regime
because it seems like that's sort of
forgotten by the American media they
lump our targeting of Chinese the chai
comes in with all the people who by the
way are the same people who say don't
trust China so you took the words right
out I'm sorry I love that guy is just he
is a gift to man or hug and boy could
could Hong Kong have called this harder
mm-hmm for Christ's sake Jesus
protesting this just ahead yeah of the
massive pandemic outbreak and let me
sing Taiwan right how they've been
excluded to from the World Health
Organization meetings and when asked
about it the guy just said oh I didn't
hear the question we ran that yesterday
the Skype call it's remarkable to me
anyway I want to get back to the
question what's your view on the
difference between the Chinese
government and the people cuz I know you
get some insight in your video which I
appreciate it well yeah I mean I I grew
up with people yeah my best friend
growing up was an expatriate from China
and so forth I mean the Chinese people I
think innately have the same desire to
go out and work and earn a living that
everyone else does but they're saddled
with this great leap four-post Great
Leap Forward regime
that's seven decades in to mass murder
and starvation and death teabagging the
entire planet and their global socialist
revolution and I think that's the
ultimate irony you know the world is
shut down and the economy is at a
standstill and people are begging daddy
governments to step in and divest them
of their personal liberty in exchange
for momentary safety to me
the Chinese have arguably achieved their
world socialist revolution arguably
arguably on a temporary basis but they
have achieved their world socialist
revolution the one they aspired to for
seventy years yeah without firing a shot
that's pretty incredible that actually
really is an interesting way to look at
it and certainly shows who their allies
are in the American media right because
the American media carried their water
it's related to the Chinese propaganda
and they did the same thing a lot of you
don't realize this when they talk about
South Korea they go look South Korea is
more successful in the United States
well hold on a second you're talking
about a place that basically has the
population density of New York City
almost the entire country is very
homogeneous which does matter with
viruses because it makes testing easier
you have a more predictable kind of
outcome and they dots their own citizens
they use personal and private data and
made it publicly available so that
people could avoid folks with a corona
virus so when they point to South Korea
as a success story I just think that you
want to be the world's most powerful
genie everything that comes with it they
need to let people know how South Korea
did it and you know what at least it be
a litmus test because maybe a lot of
Americans would say fine
I want Apple to hand over my my
targeting my location data and it want
to be Docs to publicly but at least we
know right it's the you know and that's
the shame you know if I guess every
silver lining has a black cloud I was
hoping that we would at least get rid of
kpop out of all this ya know yes there
those stands are out there man I think
that's just a little bit of sour grapes
because you and I who work online know
that nothing we ever do ever for the
rest of our lives will surpass Gangnam
style and rightfully so that was the
perfect YouTube video yes let me know
before we move on to you being manually
throttled I guess actually and I could
see in a quick question since you're
obviously a big film fan what do you
think about the film industry like the
decision now to
lease a lot of titles digitally and do
you think that maybe this is going to
become a permanent thing in the future
because this is kind of change the way I
think a lot of releases work I mean
people home viewing the experience is so
good now that I wonder if they think you
know what let's just do this wait let's
not use the multiplex petri dishes omit
some of this Robin Williams Genie ain't
going back in the bottle you know now
that y'all know businesses know that
people can work from home for cheaper
these businesses are going to keep them
there yeah
now some of that will be fire to the
process but you know if 100 percent
that's gonna happen so some of this is
gonna be permanent and that could be
part of it but I think honestly a lot of
the stuff that they're releasing not all
of it but a lot of it is well this was
obviously gonna Bob anyway so let's just
kind of kind of like that what was it
Seth Rogen movie about North Korea
that's so released after being
threatened the movie that was obviously
gonna go up like a fart in church
anyways wasn't the dictator was Sasha
Baron Cohen was a cult review the
interview the interview yeah wasn't kind
of reminds me of that that's what I
wasn't great yeah I think you're
probably right they probably say like
yeah the Mulan real-life redux yeah you
know what we'll put it for free as a
bonus on there 599 Verizon plan and
we're mostly pissed because we got all
the costumes a week we cut a parody
intro to Mulan time for the release and
then they said we're not releasing it we
said well we did all this work yep right
so you know good no good deed goes
unpunished
it's a shame that's the one thing it's a
shame movies is the one thing we don't
have a shortage of right now good point
so I am watching Ozark and of course
tiger King and I've enjoyed those
immensely so good although tiger King
could have been three episodes really it
didn't need to be seven it's printed out
but it was good
so his razorfist rageaholic is a youtube
channel before we go ask it you said you
recently had a stream taken down by CNN
and you know we're no stranger to this
with the biggest companies in the world
having forced YouTube to retool their
policies because of us what happened
with you well I mean as I'm sure you're
well aware these big media conglomerates
now are hiring outside consulting firms
to just prowl
YouTube on debate night and get stream
shut down and channels flagged and it
turns out we encountered a similar issue
apart from being a weekly targeted by
Sam cedar I mean we both we both had
streams that were pulled for copyright
under wafer-thin premises I mean I alter
the footage you can barely hear it you
can barely see it you know it's more or
less me roasting the debates yeah but it
was it was yanked by the free speech
advocates Etta and me CNN oh very nice
did you get it did you know the fist
they have another day to take me to
court or get off the pot so we'll see we
sure that's how the system works though
now because I because that's what it
used to be right they would file a
strike and then you would file a
counterclaim and they had to respond
within 14 days but then they change the
YouTube system I don't know exactly what
it is now that's why I have a half agent
learn retainer according to the
according to the email I received from
the always consistent you - yeah they
have 1014 days to take me to court or
they have to back off strike is is
absolved would be absolved yeah you
wouldn't happen to know any half Asians
what you I you know what I was gonna say
if it doesn't work out then definitely
I'll put you in touch with them but that
used to be the process that the problem
is you don't get those views back
especially when it's a live stream you
know that's what we had with the Oscars
stream when it's a lot they know that
they they never take you to court by the
way we've had this at least 1012 times
when it happens less and less now
because I think we've been somewhat
litigious not overly so but we've like I
said we're never gonna be a shark
conservatives can't be sharks on YouTube
but you can be one hell of a puffer fish
you can make them wish that they picked
someone else and so they stop trying to
take us to court but they still do abuse
the system because how many people are
watching live and how many people are
going to watch within those first 24 to
48 hours it's topical you don't get that
back and that's why the process isn't
fair and favors the big guys Yeah right
the only thing that brings me comfort is
the mental image of Jake Tapper saying
gee that sucks as he clicked the submit
copyright claim yeah and then Wolf
Blitzer right next to them just 1g that
sucks please barely I mean there are
reporters who and Jake Tapper I disagree
with them on a whole lot but Wolf
Blitzer is barely walking upright my
favorite might be ultimate Wolf Blitzer
moment is still Katrina though the sort
that's so poor and so black comment
mortal in the holiday it's love that
it's a toss-up between that and just the
the screenshot of him on celebrity
jeopardy was like negative 3,600 the
lowest score ever
not only in celebrity jeopardy but I
think ever total in jeopardy look it's
the kind of it's the kind of playing
performance if you put up on the board
at a Trivial Pursuit game game night you
know with couples they don't even want
to be with they never let you live it
down and this guy thought it was a good
idea nationally so ok this stream will
be you have two more days you said yeah
one more day actually so they have to if
the I don't know I guess hordes some
toilet paper and then they're dead off
the pot yeah either way okay good and if
not do reach out and we can have
obviously half-asian bill Richmond we
don't do this for everybody because you
know it's my retainer but you probably
need assistance right now more than I do
I don't let us know we'll be in touch
in closing where's the best place for
people to find you mr. fists and and and
what's uh what would be your thoughts
that you want to leave folks with their
well I mean you can find me on YouTube
just look up the rageaholic I'm sure
you'll find twenty- videos about me
before you find one of my videos some on
that's how the algorithm works yeah
unless of course it's the Young Turks I
noticed there's like 15 videos up there
of me saying why you ducking the razor
fist so just so you know and then on
Twitter of course razor fist with a zero
of course instead of an oh I apologize I
have the most convoluted URLs in all of
Christendom but yeah so I mean honestly
that that's pretty much where you can
beard me I'm also on [ __ ] shoot and
it's just normal it's just [ __ ] shoot
calm slash razor fist which is probably
where we're all gonna have to go
eventually it could be the water is warm
and even the even in these spell of
being entirely demonetized so we can
talk about that more sometime but off
air mr. fist
it is rageaholic rays or fists for
everyone thank you for tuning in it is
still mud Club quarantine quarantine is
the code $30 off for the entire month
we'll see you tomorrow morning live at
10 a.m. Eastern with good morning mud
club
[Music]